si neymar lors du dernier festival de
cannes il avait été l'un des favoris
pour la palme d'or pour la 20e cérémonie
des étoiles du cinéma européen le 1er
décembre à berlin
il est nommé trois fois de l'autre côté
du réalisateur germano-turc fatih akin
raconte une très belle histoire qui
traite de la tolérance du pardon de
l'immigration notre coup de coeur signé
michel vial olivier palomino même si son
nom comme son visage ne vous sont pas
encore familiers retenez l'écart fatih
akin appartient à la nouvelle génération
des cinéastes allemands son ascendance
turc a nourri les cinq longs métrages
qu'il a déjà réalisé et tout
particulièrement le dernier
prix du scénario au festival de cannes
cette année de l'autre côté celui-ci
personnages aux destins étroitement
liées qui se cherchent et se croisent
sans forcément se rencontrer entre
allemagne et turquie
un conte philosophique subtil et
émouvant qui illustre les difficultés du
métissage culturel que vous chercher
peut-être à côté de vous et vous ne le
voyez pas peut-être parce que vous ne
voulez pas le voir parfois je pensais en
écrivant que chaque personnage chaque
relation représentait aussi la relation
entre deux pays
mais l'autre côté qui évoque aussi le
film de fatih akin c'est la mort avec
les réactions qu'elles provoquent chez
les protagonistes de l'histoire en
l'occurrence elle constitue une
renaissance pour cette bourgeoise
étriqué qui retrouve les idéaux de sa
jeunesse
une composition exceptionnelle pour un
hachis goût là l'actrice fétiche de
fassbinder est sa surface est là elle va
au delà de l'ombre
au pire moment de sa vie elle rencontre
aussi les plus beaux gestes à faire
aller vers le pardon au lieu d'aller
vers d'amertume et be et oui c'est une
défaite à once you kate est une unité
avec les sentiments de fraternité qu'ils
véhiculent le film de fatih akin
sensibilise chacun de nous à la richesse
des échanges entre des mondes différents
et il donne au spectateur l'illusion
fugace d'être meilleure qu'en réalité
c'est sans doute à cette illusion qu'on
reconnaît une oeuvre d'art
je vous rappelle